I love bespoke posts because basically
what you do is you you go to you go to
box of awesome.com you take a quick quiz
and you know whoever you're giving this
to or you're giving it to yourself
basically you're getting a box every
single month with a bunch of cool stuff
in it okay
um and you never know what it's going to
be but it's all from small up and coming
Brands
manufactured in America and that's what
you want you know
um so when you get this box it's so cool
it's a great surprise and it could have
everything it could have outdoorsy stuff
it could have like uh you know stuff to
make drinks it could have like uh you
know you know fishing stuff or you know
uh boating stuff maybe it's a like a
some type of compass or something like
that
um but it's cool you know it's a fun
gift it's something you see you open it
up and go oh God you know like look at
this you know
um you know and you don't you don't know
what it'll be from month to month that's
the cool part you open it up and you go
oh my God you know it could be a fun
[__] thing Man it could be cool you
know it's just and sometimes it'll be
something where you don't quite know why
you're getting it you know but it's just
there you know I had one box that came
to me because I have it subscribe to box
of awesome I love it love it love it
one of my boxes this is wild was just
hair I had no idea whose it was hair and
a vial of blood
so this is what I mean about like always
being like huh
so get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
and enter the code Tim Dillon at
checkout that's box of awesome.com code
Tim Dylan for 20 off your first box box
of awesome.com code Tim Dillon ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the 10 million
show I am in mourning right now I am
incredibly upset I'm usually not
as upset but today is a tough day
um we're mourning the loss of a legend a
woman who's meant a lot to this show
someone who
has been an inspiration to me someone
who has been an inspiration to Millions
to young women and young men and people
of and young non-binary people everybody
uh regardless of their gender has been
impacted by this woman
um
it is a sad day in America but a very
sad day in Chicago
um because we have lost
one of the best
um an advocate
for chaos
an advocate for chaos
a woman whose reign in Chicago came to
symbolize chaos
in in the way that only a Batman villain
could like a Dick Tracy villain
like this woman presided over
an increase in crime that was
just I mean it was mind-blowing like the
numbers just kept and she was a petty
vindictive woman she went to war with
limo companies she wrote bad Yelp
reviews she was nasty to employees the
first lesbian mayor of color in Chicago
uh gotta put that in there she's a uh
and God God love her for that we
appreciate it um but this is a woman I
never thought of her as you know I never
thought of her sexuality I never thought
of even her race I thought only of what
animates her the true
um you know Spirit of Lori Lightfoot uh
is is really as a spirit of Chaos
um and let's take a look at her right
now this is her and all her glory this
is how I'll always remember her
please
there she is
[Music]
vote vote vote
yep
here she is celebrating Chicago having
the highest murder rate in the country
it's
I mean this woman
I I don't want to lose her I do not want
to lose this woman
I mean
God love her it's sad
all right well
people are listening they don't see them
that they're not getting the benefit of
this visual so we'll turn this down but
uh God I mean there's no one better than
Lori Lightfoot can we go to her speech
when she left you know Lori Lyford for
those of you who don't know was the
mayor of the city of Chicago the great
City of Chicago which is descending into
a hellscape uh how many murders last
year in Chicago just out of curiosity if
we can get that Up Chicago a violent
crime there has been a major problem
there are like they were large one of my
favorite stories was like there's large
gangs of teenagers uh groups of
teenagers just running through um you
know the Midtown of Chicago the Miracle
Mile whatever you call it and they're
just robbing couples and you know you
know just creating chaos I think they're
working for Lightfoot like I think the
kids are because here's what she's got
to do now Lori now that she has been
evicted from her uh position she's been
taken out Lori now has to wage a war
against the city from the outside
because for many years she was waging a
war against the city from the inside but
now she's now from the outside has to
like make sure the city stays as crime
ridden and filthy
from the outside she's just got a launch
attacks
coordinating attacks the year of 2021
Ended as one of the most violent on
record in Chicago a rise in the number
of shootings left more people dead than
in any single year and a quarter century
according to statistics
released by the police on Saturday
797 homicides
20 more 25 more than were recorded in
2020. it's about 800 homicides how many
a day is 365 days in a year almost like
three a day yeah there's about three
people a day in Chicago checking out
and uh you know this was also you got to
remember Lori Lightfoot went wild with
the vaccine she was threatening people
saying if you don't take the vaccine
your time has come we'll put you in jail
you know we're gonna find you again this
was the language of a of a villain this
was the language of like an all-powerful
mob boss it was not a governor here we
go
um yeah she did not [__] around when it
came to the vaccine she was like
nazi-ish she wanted everybody to get it
and if you didn't get it she did that
whole thing get up that thing where she
goes we'll put you in jail yeah that was
my favorite one where she goes we'll put
you in jail
she goes we will put you in jail and it
was just like you saw that was like the
Zenith of state power during the
pandemic when people were just coming
right out and saying if there is
anything you do that we disagree with we
are going to put you in jail and that
was like I remember people sending that
to me going like this is going to really
like be a huge problem for this woman
and it was you know people you play that
back now it seems so insane
um here it is right here
this is Lori Lightfoot we will shut you
down we will cite you and if we need to
we will arrest you and we will take you
to jail period there should be nothing
unambiguous about that you mean nothing
ambiguous treat you like a criminal but
if you act like a criminal and you
violate the law and you refuse to do
what is necessary to save lives in the
city in the middle of a pandemic we will
take you to jail get up here get up when
she did Rona Destroyer I just this is a
montage of Lori Lightfoot I I am so sad
to be losing this woman I hope she runs
for governor
I pray that Lori Lightfoot runs for
governor
looks trick-or-treating will be
happening in Chicago this year
[Laughter]
yeah that's Chicago mayor Lori Lightfoot
coming out in full costume cape and mask
is the Rona as in Corona Destroyer
heading out Kenny to reporters and staff
at our daily news conference
trick-or-treaters will be asked to stay
in groups of six or fewer there avoid
sticking their hands into any candy
bowls and of course wear a mask with a
mask over
man she's a symbol of the pandemic isn't
she Lori Lightfoot I think now Cove is
finally over
I mean I know the state of emergency was
lifted in LA but with Lori Lightfoot
leaving
it's like the state like it really is
over
this is finally done
with Lori Lightfoot
being voted out
this is sad let's look at our concession
speech here
she doesn't even seem present in her own
body
for the concession speech again so much
Mayhem
so much chaos
so bloody
this woman was the ultimate villain the
only this is the type of Mayor Chicago
should have it's one of the most corrupt
cities in the world and there's
absolutely no way it should be run by
anyone left like anyone less than a
complete utter uh crime uh boss which is
what she is
she is like you know
somebody who from uh like the Ninja
Turtles would have to invade her Lair
let's see how she conceded the election
we
uh for the people of the city for years
to come I'm grateful that we work
together to remove a record number of
guns off our streets we're doing we're
due homicides and started making real
progress on Public Safety well she
didn't she didn't reduce homicide I mean
that's but who cares at this point and I
don't know what gun she's talking about
that are off the street certainly not
the 900 you know murders she didn't
really reduce any homicides but now she
can live with her wife and be happy and
like
you know just she was the mayor of
Chicago you know she'll just always
She'll always be able to tell people
like later on she'll be on some like
lesbian cruise and they're like what did
you do and she'll go I was the mayor of
Chicago and you go Laurie was the mayor
of Chicago she just cheated at cards
Laurie was the mayor of Chicago because
she's corruption is the DNA of Chicago
and it runs through this woman's veins
no matter what she does any any time in
her life
she will always try to lie and this is
what I love about her so much is that no
matter what Lori life I mean she
literally just said we we we we we uh we
what about homicide she goes we decrease
homicides they were at the highest level
in 25 years but it doesn't matter she'll
always try to lie first that's what I
love about her she just it's her in you
can tell when you look at her she's
burning inside because she doesn't know
what's true anymore because there's so
much she's lied so many times
did you ever see the thing where the the
guy he just lists everything in Chicago
it's Lori Lightfoot she refuses to
answer a question and it's great you
have a guy who basically comes up and
goes here's the issue the crime's up
this is up they don't want companies are
leaving Chicago nobody wants to be here
anymore and Lori Lightfoot stands there
and goes I'm just not gonna answer that
question
um
you got to remember the fashion choices
too she wore these big balloon pants she
dressed up during the St Patrick's Day
Parade they were saying on Twitter that
she looked like that movie Leprechaun in
the Hood they were saying she looked
like Leprechaun in the Hood
um it was she was trolling everyone or
she wasn't
she had these weird balloon pants these
baggy like Janko jeans but they were
pants that she would wear and they like
never fit her
this is a kid who dressed up as her
but I mean I'm really gonna be sad to
see her go man
try to get that up where she refuses to
answer the question where she literally
just looks at the guy and she goes I I
disagree with your assessment entirely
and he just listed
facts about what was happening in
Chicago and she goes I just disagree
with your assessment uh entirely but I
mean it's sad man it's sad to lose her
because she became such a symbol of uh
the type of political leader that we
have
um in America now where truth is
irrelevant okay this is great Lightfoot
now screams this is this was another one
but this is also great he or she is
screaming at a reporter over a question
about crime God I love her
other right-wing nuts can try to
characterize it any possible excuse me
is that appropriate yeah is that
appropriate I mean Kelly
mayor Lightfoot
the people that I speak with in Chicago
every day tell me that they're very
frustrated with your lack of a plan to
combat violent crime
[Music]
it sounds more like you support or
sympathize with the the so you you may
not have heard the admonition at the
beginning of this press conference and
frankly
hold on sir it's specific to you
ask a question and I'd be happy to
respond but if you continue to come in
here and spout a lot of nonsense and
rhetoric if that's not a question and
not acting like a journalist then I'm
not going to have any time for you
you've had a whole room of people that
you're Holding On by not asking a
question and I know you like to film me
and then you like to go on Fox News
filming you yeah so I might want to
reporter what I want you to do is ask a
question sir don't give me your right
wing nonsense and spewing of facts that
are completely untethered from the
reality just ask the question that's all
I'm asking you ask a question so we can
move on well I'm not the only reporter
filming ask a question
right what's your question the obvious
question is simply this
there are numerous uh
violent crimes here in the city of
Chicago right last night a teenager was
shot in the head uh on our beautiful
Lake Front people around the city the
state and not only the country but
around the world I'm going to ask you to
Chicago
[Music]
a question or we're moving she's like
yeah I shot that [__]
they're like um some teenager was shot
Lori's like on my orders I had it done
I'm the boss this is when Oswald get up
Oswald cobblepot running for mayor of
Gotham City this is when the penguin ran
Gotham City like Lori Lightfoot staring
at him he's like he goes I don't
understand you don't have a plan to
combat the crime
she's like yeah I am the criminal
I wonder if we can play this or if
YouTube's gonna like you know send
someone to our homes
it's getting so bad over there you you
can't do anything they'll send people
after you in the Street YouTube If you
play the wrong thing you're fit they'll
call and threaten your family we're
trying to stay the world anyway don't
play it it's just you get it folks if
you've seen Batman Returns
the point is that Lightfoot symbolize
the type of politician
where they didn't even try to lie uh in
a way that would make the citizenry feel
comfortable this is an important
transition It's actually an important
transition in the way things are kind of
uh crumbling uh when someone like her
basically went out warts and all
imperfect
came out and was like listen I'm kind of
a criminal so I'm not going to sit in
Judgment of other people that were
criminals
um and now listen you have many many
liars that occupy uh offices all over
the place from Congress to the governors
but there was something special about
this woman in in in my heart I like
Petty people and when she did the thing
and you could go back and listen to that
old episode where she ratted on her limo
company she literally made up that the
driver of the limo company went and used
the bathroom in her home and then the
company goes we have cameras he didn't
enter your house once she's such a
vindictive liar
even on a tiny small scale this
infinitesimal scale of trying to get a
limo driver fired
she is just such a treat
she's such an utter treat
a um you know there's something so
comforting to me about her complete like
obvious disdain for anyone who called
her out on anything anyone that would
mention a fact about Chicago the
shootings the murders the crime she
hated it she was like don't bring your
propaganda here and I love her [__]
weird voice she had like she had this
weird like breathy voice where she'd be
like listen to me if you have a question
ask a question don't bring your Fox
propaganda here don't bring your
propaganda
this strange kind of
like her voice box almost didn't want to
lie and she had to like force the breath
through it because like her body was
shutting down some of the lies that she
was telling and she what did she get 16
of the vote
God Laurie it was bad it was like at
least it was bad she got trounced
17. 17.1 percent who are those people
just committed criminals and I mean who
were the
who were the 17.1 percent of people that
voted for Lori Lightfoot like every
measurable standard Chicago's falling
into an uh it's a hellscape and 17.1
percent of people
I mean what was their slope did
Lightfoot of a slogan
did Lori have like a slogan
everything even even her name's amazing
Lori Lightfoot just it's just the
alliteration you know Lori Lightfoot
there's just no one better
and I'm uh I'm sad to see her go you
know of all the people we [__] talk on
this show
you know there was nobody that that I
loved and had a personal affinity for
more than Lori Lightfoot she just fit I
mean the fedoras she dressed like a
gangster again like somebody like Dick
Tracy would have to like I mean Lori
Lightfoot epitomized she looked like a
gangster she was a gangster she lied she
you know obfuscated she wouldn't answer
questions and all around her things just
totally fell apart because she was a
petty vindictive Tyrant that would go to
war with people in her Inner Circle and
she would fight these tiny small battles
instead of focusing on real things that
could actually help people and there's
no better version of a politician than
that to me it's just somebody who's like
it's all out in the open what they do
that's what made Lori Lightfoot so
special to me she was so bad at
concealing it she almost had no desire
to conceal it she just thought like
somehow it was gonna be okay you know
you've all you know seen a kid or maybe
you've been the kid who shows up to
class without homework and has no lie
nothing prepared they just go huh and
the teacher goes uh you have nothing and
they go I yeah that was Lori Lightfoot
no dog ate my homework no oh I left it
in the car no it was 100
I don't have it and I don't remember you
even uh asking it uh asking me to do it
and I don't know what your problem is
and I'm just gonna stare at you from my
seed until you give up
and there's something about that I do
miss
uh I do miss her be smart don't start
kick the habit put it out before it puts
you out All Phases phrases we've heard a
hundred times yet we could continue to
have bad habits our sponsor fume is on a
mission to accelerate Humanities break
up from the bad habits that consume too
many of us fume is a natural diffusive
device that uses plants and Behavioral
Science to help you trade out your
negative habit for positive one fume is
not a vape it's a non-electronic device
designed to transform your negative
habits instead of PODS filled with
potentially harmful chemicals like a
vape fume uses courses infused with
cores infused with plants like
peppermint and cinnamon for delicious
natural flavors wow with an adjustable
airflow dial and a magnetic end cap your
fingers will always have something to do
I love the look and the feel of this and
the taste
you know and I didn't think I would like
all three but I I do
when I started using fume many people in
my life were skeptical
of it
and I'm no longer friends with them I
cut them out because I don't tolerate
people like that in my life
so I'd love to say that now that I've
been using fumes successfully those
people have learned a thing or two but
like I said I am a vault and they will
can no longer come near me
but I know how well fumas worked
that's the point
head to trifum.com and use code Tim to
save 10 off when you get the journey
packed today the journey pack comes with
three unique flavors and the new version
two fumed out Kickstart your positive
habits that's
trifum.com and use code Tim to save an
additional 10 off on your order Magic
spoon this is the cereal that has no
sugar I'm telling you right now it's got
13 14 grams of protein four to five net
grams of carbs per serving
I mean they have great flavors so this
thing is keto friendly gluten-free grain
free soy free it's a way to relive those
moments watching your favorite cartoons
plus it's only 140 calories a serving
it's like there's magic in every
Spoonful with over eight unique flavors
you won't get bored feeling good with
magic spoon my favorite flavors are
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
people love the waffle honey nut cookies
and cream cinnamon roll don't you feel
healthier
they're super popular previously limited
edition only flavor is back to stay
birthday cake is the flavor uh we're
celebrating our birthdays early with
this fan favorite I love the first time
I got magic spoon I was like I can't
believe it I I can't believe it I said
because it tasted like cereal
but it wasn't unhealthy
that's when I started to lose my mind I
was literally wondering
if I died and woke up in heaven
with cereal that tasted like it was
sugar cereal but it wasn't
go to magicspoon.com Tim Dillon to grab
a custom bundle of cereal and try the
magic for yourself
and be sure to use our promo code Tim
Dillon at checkout to save five dollars
off your order magicspoon.com
I'm telling you this is one of those
things that changes people's lives a
friend of mine
was a big fat even batty and started
taking uh Magic spoon they were eating
it every day for every meal and they
lost 300 pounds and now they're 16
pounds and they look phenomenal go to
magicspoon.com Tim Dillon McDonald's is
very angry that uh or well certain
franchisees the people that own the
McDonald's franchises because you
remember McDonald's is a conglomerate
it's like the biggest company one of
those top five or something something
crazy
but then there's people that own
franchises of McDonald's all over the
place so McDonald's is doing these
celebrity meals now which I don't know
why they're doing this right I've never
fully understood why they're doing these
celebrity meals
were they and it's usually like uh J
Balvin had one
how many other people have had like
celebrity meals Travis Scott Travis
Scott had one yeah and I don't I don't
understand why they're doing but
apparently they sell really well because
young people are like I want to eat
Travis Scott's meal
now they're doing a meal with cardi B
and offset and apparently
some of the franchisees at McDonald's
are upset because
they don't like the value system of
cardi being offsack because I don't know
she was a gang member used to drug dudes
it was a stripper or whatever who cares
who do you think's eating at McDonald's
who the hell do you think's eating at
McDonald's it's 14 year old kids that
want to shoot people
the McDonald's biggest demo is young
kids who want to get into gangs
so why wouldn't you not give them a meal
give them a good meal
most like for example after them because
you we've all seen these fights it's you
know it's in the city and it's a
McDonald's I'm not I'm not because by
the way we we all know that white people
are very violent and there's tons of
white trash and they fight in McDonald's
too okay but my point is that we've all
seen a McDonald's fight where it's in
the city
and the kids are just beating someone
they're just stopping a [__] out
stopping on their face
now those kids afterwards want to eat
after the fight after the cops come and
everybody runs away and the ambulance
comes and takes the one kid to the
hospital
and then oh the crowd
comes back because they're like I'm all
of that stomping on the face made me
hungry so they come back and they get
the cardi B meal and by the way what is
the cardi B offset meal what do you get
what's included oh it's a bundle so it's
like it's a valentine it's like a a
bundle for the young couples yeah so
it's a classic cheeseburger with
barbecue sauce a large Coke and a
quarter pounder with cheese and a large
Hi-C orange lava good good
yet no one's gonna be offended by this
who would eat at McDonald's
if you are eating at McDonald's this is
not offensive to you you want more of it
if you're eating at McDonald's they
don't care it doesn't matter
it's a [__] disgusting place where
people that don't really have choices
eat
and they don't pay anywhere I love
McDonald's you're like we're morally
concerned with these rappers you don't
pay anyone
you don't pay anyone my mother knew a
woman named Marianne she worked at
McDonald's for years she had like five
kids and like she barely had any money
at all and she was like the manager of
McDonald's for like 40 years like and
she made nothing McDonald's pays [__] in
and out pays really well McDonald's
doesn't pay that well McDonald's poisons
everybody and I've eaten McDonald's
clearly but they poison people there's
sugar the fat the it's horrific it's
that meal could kill someone this cardi
B offset meal the calories in the meal
the sugar in the meal could kill someone
but they're not concerned about that
they're concerned that it's there's
rappers promoting it so these
franchisees that are probably white and
they're from like Middle America and
they own McDonald's is are like we don't
want did cardi B being a meal because
it's not our values so they you know
who knows what they want they want a
proud boy meal probably which they want
to McDonald's will have but what's
interesting is like um McDonald's pushed
back on the internet criticism noting
the feedback it has received
um
uh a court you know it is received the
collaboration with the rappers was
generating support and excitement among
his franchisees so like Hey listen
there's some feedback there's some
criticism but there's a lot more
excitement that's like what McDonald's
is saying what are people like what are
the franchisees saying that's disturbing
them so much here
I saw a good one once where this girl
was popping [__] in a McDonald's running
her mouth
and then a bunch of other girls
surrounded her in a circle and I think
they killed her
I all I think they killed her or maybe
paralyzed her
and and and because don't you understand
like this is McDonald's
yeah they have this golden arches code
the golden arches code of marketing
guidelines for store owners and
employees Partnerships with celebrities
and influencers that have a potential
risk to damage our brand your brand
of poison the brand is poisoning
children that's McDonald's brand we
poison kids
um so people got met it's kind of a
culture shock thing when you consider
that McDonald's brand over the years
said dick Adams a former McDonald's
restaurant owner and consultant to
franchisees especially if you're a
franchise owner and you're 50 or six
years old you don't have any kids and
haven't been exposed to the type of
these lyrics well because they're mad
because she does did that song wet ass
[__]
right again I don't understand who they
think's eating at McDonald's it's single
mothers
it's people that are that it's like
someone who's eating at McDonald's okay
is probably if I had to demographic it
is a single mother from the hood sorry
it is a single mom from the hood
at because we've done a horrible job in
this country uh providing a better
alternative at the price point right so
for the price point you probably have a
single mother from the hood eating at
McDonald's
and you know that's who's going there
you're not getting like people that are
flush with money McDonald now some
people occasionally will eat McDonald's
as a novelty but the people your your
day ones like the people that are coming
in to eat all the time are not offended
by the wet ass [__] lyrics in fact
they're wet ass [__] has uh had several
illegitimate children pop out of it
which is why they're eating at
McDonald's
so it's just a matter of knowing who you
are as a brand it's just a matter of
knowing who you are as a brand like
McDonald's is a place that is catering
to people that that have problems they
have issues you don't wanna you wanna
you don't want to hear that McDonald you
think it's wholesome you think it's
wholesome anymore I've watched people
get their heads cracked on your floor
these McDonald's fight can we get a
McDonald's fight up please there's
compilations on Worldstar look at this
this is the brand they're concerned with
damaging
get it
yeah yep
let's go oh the fries wet
this is the brand they don't want to
damage
what are they fighting over the filet of
fish
this is the staff
there we go
there it is
what's McDonald's uh thing what is it
what's it called I'm loving it
I'm loving it
look at somebody at the drive-through
well there you go this is uh this is the
brand that nobody wants damaged here uh
it's a [__] and the people who eat
there are desperate and have no hope
that is your brand it is no longer like
a nice brand where young families go uh
if you're taking your kid to McDonald's
on the weekends it is not knowing what
you know now is literally child abuse
you are abusing your child and the state
should take your child from you if you
go more than once a year our parents
used to take us all the time and
everybody I know is a morbidly obese
drug addict because of that okay so the
reality is uh McDonald's is a
grotesquery and anyone participating in
it
I kind of want it now though that I've
been talking about it for a little bit
but I mean this idea that they don't
like that their brand is being in free I
mean it's just it's just such a [__]
like complete
misunderstanding of who eats at your
restaurant and why
truly and who works who's working there
it's a joke working at McDonald's
means that things are not good you do
not care about the cardi B meal and the
music that the offensive lyrics to the
song when you're working at McDonald's
trust me you've got bigger fish to fry
bigger filet of fish to fry everybody in
America right now is bald and it's
disgusting go to keeps to keep the hair
that you have on your hair so many of my
friends were losing their hair and I
said stop it but then they did they took
keeps two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35 more than 50 million men
in the US suffer from male pattern
baldness keeps us more five star reviews
than any of its competitors they offer
simple affordable stress-free way to
keep your hair and I'm telling you
that's the best way to do it is to keep
your hair you know I'm telling you this
is the way it works folks
keeps us a network of Expert Medical
advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality
each treatment plan comes with a full
year of unlimited messaging so you can
connect with your medical provider about
anything anytime treatment plans are
affordable typical typically half the
cost of Pharmacy prices whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
your hair that you have keeps as you
covered remember prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keps.com Tim Dillon to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-p-s.com Tim Dillon
to get your first month of treatment
free
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Tim Dylan I've been
in multiple car accidents I've totaled
multiple cars
this is true I've totaled five cars
um
in 2020 there were over five million car
crashes that's more than fifteen
thousand a day in 600 an hour it's so
shocked that's so shocking to me
how did Insurance handle it the injured
party get what they were entitled to
they think of
or have to sue
did you know that you can sue when
you're in an accident to be made whole
did you know that you're not suing the
person to hit you rather their insurance
company
did you know that you don't need a lot
of money to hire a lawyer
not everyone does
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan Morgan
is America's largest injury Law Firm
they have over 100 offices Nationwide
and more than 800 lawyers with over 15
billion dollars recovered for clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair compensation submitting an injury
claim with Morgan and Morgan is so easy
it's more like using an app than hiring
a lawyer
if you're ever injured in an accident
you can check out Morgan and Morgan
their fee is free unless they win for
more information go to forthepeople.com
Tim well I like the sound of that for
the people.com champ or dial pound law
pound 529 from your cell phone that's
for the people.com Tim or pound law
pound 529 from yourself you can even do
it in your car after the accident if you
can still you know you just remember
that pound five two nine
California has its share of problems and
really the reality is Florida is the
next uh this is the thing right so I
mean this is by the way so this is a
video of the lifestyle in Florida and
how it differs from California and how
it is beautiful and it is welcoming and
let's just take a look here at again
zero taxes uh beautiful climate Florida
it's terrifying video of an alligator
moving in for the kill he's about to
attack an unsuspecting 85 year old
grandmother walking her dog by a lake
the horrifying drama at a retirement
community in Fort Pierce Florida was
caught on a wildlife camera oh my God
the alligator is better the victim's
frantic neighbor can be heard on this
just released 911
you don't I don't have anything to get
to her the call was made by 76 year old
Carol Thomas who was watching from her
Lakefront home as glorious Serge was
attacked while walking her beloved dog
trooper
and the gator grabbed the dog and took
her fell down is she alive
she's alive
she's holding her in
her hands alike she fetched this pole to
try to pull the stricken woman to shore
too late oh my god
oh no I was trying to stick the hell out
of her and I was calling you at the same
time and I she's wrong okay she's gone
it's horrible for her family it's hard
no state income tax what does this do
you think in La the cops aren't coming
anymore
the police aren't coming yeah they're
considering not sending them to a whole
bunch of cars sounds good
[Laughter]
sounds good Florida
Rhonda Sanders
I'm gonna [__] an old woman in Florida
and live with her because this state can
go to hell it is a disgusting it is
snowing and hailing and it is a
nightmare and everybody's like it's a
leg Yeah it's The Vibes in LA City it's
about sex in the last six baby
and it's hailing and snowing and a
homeless person is smearing their bloody
[__] on the [__] window and it is a
night they are robbing people in broad
daylight here they're hopping in your
car putting a gun in your head and
saying here Florida
uh I'm going to Florida it is uh it's
not even warm anymore it's not even and
everyone is has Stockholm syndrome
they're like well it's gonna get better
it's gonna get better it's gonna get
better it's gonna this is like a freak
thing it's a freak thing it's gonna get
better
of course it'll get better in the spring
that's the whole [__] point
everywhere is nice in the [__] spring
Christ almighty and now they're the cops
aren't even gonna come and and listen
sometimes that's good because the LAPD
is not exactly the best they're not
exactly always on point but you would
you know if somebody close so what what
what is it here's the list
in its entirety can be found below these
are these are things cops won't come to
now some of them it might make sense
let's see non-criminal and or
non-violent homeless and public quality
of life calls okay so that might be
interesting and non-violent or
non-criminal homeless qualities so like
I have a homeless person in my yard
we don't need to send the cops for that
we you can just reason with the violence
schizophrenic and see what happens
non-criminal mental health cause
makes sense there's a guy on your street
going like this
[Music]
what's the problem with that what's the
problem with that
or like you know some of them they walk
up and down the street and they're
literally talking to someone who's not
dead like oh [__] you well
and you go yeah what's the problem with
that what's the problem with that
a social worker send somebody there to
be like how are you feeling
um
non-violent calls for service at city
parks sure I don't know what that means
Under the Influence calls alcohol and or
drugs where there is another no crime in
progress so someone who is on out who is
drinking or really drugged up
and you might go hey I'm at the park and
I have my kids here and there's a crazy
homeless man who seems to be on many
many drugs and they go have a nice day
uh non-fatal vehicle accidents
interesting okay
parking violations driveway towel
abandoned vehicles person dumping trash
vicious and Dangerous Dog complaints
where no attack is in progress
okay
calls for service for loud noise loud
music or party calls that are Anonymous
or have no victim
landlord tenant disputes loitering
trespassing with no indication of danger
so
you let them come in
you let him come in
trespassing with no indications yeah I
just wanted to see Taylor Swift's yard
just wanted to see it
I like that
code 30 alarm response
syringe disposal
that makes sense just hi there's
somebody who keeps throwing syringes in
my shut up
hi someone keeps throwing syringes in my
uh defecating urinating in public look
at 20
28 suspicious
circs possible dead body where no
indication of Foul Play great leave the
body there leave the body there why get
the pigs involved with a dead body
why call the cops over a dead body it's
California the greatest state in the
nation and this idiot Gavin Newsom
really thinks he's going to run for
president there's like middle-aged [__]
boy [__] believes he's gonna run for
president the state is a laughing stock
it's a national embarrassment and a joke
everyone hates it and I know people like
someone in his orbit they kind of chat
chat a little he thinks he's got like a
shot and brought maybe Elon does too
because that's why Elon moved Tesla back
here so that maybe he thinks within four
to eight years there will be a Newsome
presidency and he can hand them all
those free contracts government
contracts I don't really know but
I mean this is just hilarious most
California voters don't want Newsom to
run for president 70 percent of Voters
don't want to run for president
they should want him to run away
I mean this is like hilarious here a
dead body they may not send police for a
dead body who do you call Uber Eats
I mean who would you call Postman what
are they gonna they're gonna send people
without guns or without weapons in our
place okay so Union reps say the
establishment of an unarmed response
protocol will help with the police
department's chronic understaffing
problem and allow police to focus on the
actual job of responding to emergencies
not these things like some drunk
defecating uh person next to a dead body
that's fine
the decision to trim back armed
responses by sworn officers is an
alternative policing approach
that has been deployed in other major
cities to varying levels in the wake of
wide-scale civil unrest caused by deadly
police slaying of civilians right so
basically the decision to trim this back
as uh Twitter we decided that it would
make Twitter happy and uh only thought
people were tweeting so this is good in
Virginia armed officers have responded
here's my thing I also don't think that
you need cops in every situation all the
time but there's a lot of [__] things
there that probably could use police
there's a lot of things there where
somebody's heavily intoxicated or being
suspicious something weird something bad
is about to happen something bad may
happen and the idea that you're going to
get rid of any type of police response
and the people are not going to be armed
they're not going to be you're just
going to let things get to a point where
it's going to be very difficult to deal
with them after they've happened
that's what's going to happen when you
when you're basically saying we're going
to ignore something until someone gets
stabbed or someone gets shot or there is
an altercation
it's not good you you don't you know and
I know that everybody's like well
they're just running around streets
killing people listen we got to get
better with the training with cops
you know at least Lori made it fun see
Lori made it fun Gavin doesn't even make
it fun
Laurie made it fun Laurie met you rooted
for the chaos with Lori right I rooted
for Lori you know I rooted for her she's
a figure that you root for because she
is a a mob boss and now she must take
her place
amongst the shadows in the shadows and
she must launch full-scale attacks like
the Riddler on Gotham City
there must be no [__] let up
Lightfoot you were to continue to raise
hell
you were not to fall back
but it's it's just amazing I I just the
idea of like Lori Lightfoot on a lesbian
Cruise playing shuffleboard cheating and
then having someone go what did Lori do
to go she was the mayor of Chicago
she was the criminal mayor of Chicago
the Great American city
um yeah I mean this is so funny well
listen God bless I mean this is what uh
this is what you get right it's like hey
maybe it'll work maybe it'll work maybe
ignoring the dead bodies will work I
don't know
I mean there's you know you would you
would think that it wouldn't uh be
perfect but you know what do I know
maybe this is not um
maybe this is not uh as bad as it seems
you know this is a
this is a state where people should
experiment I was up in the Pacific
Northwest recently and
the thing about the Pacific Northwest is
that it is uh insane
and a lot of the Cities up there you
know again it's just something about the
West Coast there's just something about
the West Coast where people are a bit
off
maybe it's when you leave SoCal you
don't get a lot of vitamin D when you go
up there you get almost no vitamin D
something about the people is a bit off
and uh you know they they kind of like
it they like it the way it is you know
where it's just like endless tent cities
and a lot of mentally unstable people in
the streets and like downtowns being
overrun with chunkies and crime it's
like hey man you know if let's if you're
into it you're into it like that's my
thing it's like if you're into it you're
into it I'm not going to tell you what
to be into it's like you know I'm not
gonna Kink shame you do what you do if
you get off on the idea that there's a
bunch of psychopaths running around
downtown of your city and you're like a
young professional but it makes you feel
better about yourself which I guess it
does these people they feel better about
themselves they're going and they're
like I believe that they're right to do
whatever they want to do stab me again
uh these people should be able to just
this is what they want these are the
areas they've created they keep voting
for this [__] they keep they want it I
don't know what to say it seems not good
you know when I go and I see all the
crazy people running on the streets and
go that seems unsustainable but then
you'll talk to people and they go well
actually it's so much better than it was
you know there's they removed a few of
the tenths and I think that uh we're
heading in the right direction you know
they can't take the people's stuff
though because you see that woman there
I mean that's her thing so the cops
shouldn't be able to move her things and
occasionally she goes nuts and then runs
into traffic but this is her right you
know this is what this is who she is and
why would we like stop her from behaving
that way and you know they're just like
eating like organic food in a place and
then you know as people walk by and as
the end of the world just marches on
outside the end of the world just
marches past people and they just go
well you know I just think that it's
very complicated it's a very strange
situation you're like well maybe you
could just you know bust up these things
and get these people to [__] out of wow
that's actually harder than that because
a lot of people they're trying and it's
very difficult there's a lot of problems
it's very layered I'm like well that
guy's shooting heroin in front of me and
maybe that's less complicated he's
shooting heroin he's using Hera maybe
that's why he's homeless because he's
doing heroin well that's actually the
rents have gone up their rents are
higher I know they are but he's doing
heroin right now and now he's attacking
a woman I know but there's a lot of
protest late stage capital I know that's
not great that's certainly not ideal but
now he's choking that woman to death you
see him choking her to death over there
do you think that requires some
immediate response well there's an
unarmed civilian force that can be
dealing with that and they'll go to him
now assess where you know it's like oh
God just let him have it then [__]
let him out I'm I'm sick of arguing with
these [__] people and that might mean
you'll have to live in a [__]
right-wing nightmare where [__]
nobody gets abortions and they ban
anything that's cool and you're just you
know you're living in the [__] like
like some weird theocracy I don't know
but I mean uh you know it's just uh it's
getting silly it's getting silly in this
place and I don't know what to tell
people other than just [__] like I
don't know folks figure it out you know
figure your stuff out but if you're a
McDonald's
franchisee the last thing you have to
worry about is a [__] cardi B meal
enough will you stop please
act like it's a country club well we're
the our people will be very offended
by the we must have a wholesome image
here at McDonald's this is where people
buy [__] pills in our parking lot
what about the drug dealers who sell
Percocet in our parking lot here in
[__] Ohio they're gonna be upset I
don't think they'll have cheeseburgers
anymore if they find out someone who's
selling cheeseburger said the word [__]
in a song
I mean do these people live on [__]
Earth do they live on [__] Earth
people are giving birth in your bathroom
they're having children in the bathroom
and those are your employees
so I wouldn't worry about it
timberlandcomedy.com for all your
tickets
uh to any Live Events let's tell people
where I'm going to be I'm in Oklahoma
City this week and this is coming out
Saturday so if you're not there already
[__] you but Oklahoma City March 9th
through the 11th I'm in Palm Beach
Florida uh the great Palm Beach maybe
the greatest city in the United States
the richest they are getting mad in Palm
Beach now because the old money is
fighting with the New York new money the
old Palm Beach women where the Lilly
Pulitzer and the pearls and it's very
colorful and these new New York uh dikes
are coming in there with all black and
flat hair and they look super trendy and
they're not [__] assimilating
assimilate this see this is what I mean
Palm Beach you better Build That Wall
because the New York money is coming in
and they're being cons Palm Beach
Florida uh thanks I'm sorry not
Thanksgiving
um uh the [__] day for the My People
the mix St Patrick's Day I'll be in Napa
California it's our rescheduled date
because of the flooding in the hell Napa
California Raleigh the 24th and the 25th
Raleigh
um April 7th Prior Lake Minnesota April
8th Grand Rapids Michigan Thursday April
13th Inglewood New Jersey April 14th
Huntington New York 15th of April New
Brunswick New Jersey uh Sunday April 16
Huntington New York again April 21st
Peoria Illinois the 22nd Kansas City
Missouri the 28th Portland Oregon the
29th Tacoma Washington and I didn't mean
anything I said about the West Coast
I didn't mean it but I think maybe some
of the people uh coming to see with me
will uh agree with me I do not know uh
we support cardi B and offset and their
uh meal I think McDonald's should do
like the most controversial meal
Kanye West Kanye West would be a very
controversial meal but I think they do
you know what if they got to give
everybody something
do the Kyle Rittenhouse meal
that's what it's lacking do a Kyle
Written House meal okay and the Kyle
Rittenhouse meal would be like a Big Mac
a [__] cheese curds because he was
from Wisconsin Right Kenosha Wisconsin
so I'll be a Big Mac
uh some cheese curds and a [__] I
don't know flurry a McFlurry yeah he's a
little bit of a Porker
he's a little bit of a chubby he's a
fatty boom Baddie he's lost some weight
though but yeah McFlurry a Big Mac and
some cheese curds the Kyle Rittenhouse
meal and now we every they should just
do one meal that will appeal to Inner
City youth which is a huge demo and then
another meal to appeal to White Trash
another one those are the two demos of
McDonald's
inner city stomp on her face violent
youth coming from the high school and
white trash cousin [__] who eat the
call Rittenhouse meal those are your
Democrats not like all like what does
McDonald's things happening like a
wholesome family is sitting there and
they're like hello this is McDonald's
we're all gonna have a nice time
together that's not what's happening
it's not it's something like single
mother that's just like [__] beating
the [__] out of her kid she's like eat
your kid
I'm telling you these people are out of
it the car written asked meal we should
we should do that we should [__]
I'll tweet at them I'll go how about you
do a [__] Kyle Rittenhouse meal you
[__] losers
well anyway folks we appreciate you
listening we'll see you on patreon.com
the Tim Dillon show
uh live tickets are on sale we're having
so much fun doing stand-up all around
the country
um should be great to see you guys there
and um we hope you are doing well we'll
see you soon